Few people have heard of Walter Pitts
despite his revolutionary ideas that
helped set the stage for artificial intelligence.
He was one of the first to show that
the brain functioned like a computer.
But just when his career was taking off,
a series of tragic circumstances led him
to destroy his research, withdraw from
academia, and succumb to alcoholism.
This is the story of the scientist who should have
been famous but instead died alone and unknown.
You could say the odds of Walter Pitts
becoming a scientist were not in his favor.
Born in Detroit on April 23, 1923, his father
and brothers were rough and uneducated.
His dad actually wanted him
to quit school to get a job.
But Walter was brilliant.
As a child, he taught himself to
read Latin, Greek, and Sanskrit.
He found solace in math, with logic
being the antidote to his chaotic life.
The story goes that while hiding from
bullies one day at the age of 12,
he ran into the library and stumbled
upon a copy of Principia Mathematica,
a three-volume work that tried to show that
all math can be explained by using pure logic.
He didn’t leave the library, even after closing.
For the next three days,
Walter pored over the 2,000 pages
and sent a letter to its co-author,
Bertrand Russell, pointing out what
he considered mistakes in his work.
Three years later, when he was 15,
and heard Bertrand was going to be
lecturing at the University of Chicago, he
ran away from home and went off to Illinois.
He never spoke with his family again,
except for sending home an anonymous
Christmas present every year.
For the next few years, he was unofficially
enrolled at the University of Chicago.
While hanging around campus, a young medical
student he befriended, Jerome Lettvin introduced
him to Warren McCulloch, a professor of psychiatry
at the University of Illinois at Chicago.
McCulloch wanted to learn how the brain worked,
delving into the process by which the
firing of neurons transforms into thoughts.
Walter understood what was required,
and knew how to model it mathematically.
McCulloch took him under his wing and into
his home, where they tackled this question.
Their groundbreaking paper in 1943 envisioned
the brain as a collection of tiny switches,
each one turning on or off like a light
bulb, and these switches working together
to create thoughts and decisions.
McCulloch eagerly declared to a group
of philosophy students: “For the first time in
the history of science, we know how we know.”
It marked the first time anyone seriously
likened the brain to a computer.
Their insight into how neurons operate paved
the way for the creation of neural networks,
now central to the machine learning revolution.
Mathematician John von Neumann,
based his design on one of the
earliest electronic computers (EDVAC) on
Pitts and McCulloch’s model of the brain.
Walter Pitts was a rising star.
Fortune magazine included him in its list of the
top ten young scientists at
U.S. universities in 1954.
Walter shied away from this
type of public attention,
seldom even signing his name to anything.
Following his groundbreaking paper,
his friend Jerry Lettvin once again
played a crucial in introducing him to
another influential scientist, this time,
the renowned mathematician Norbert
Wiener at MIT who pioneered the field
of cybernetics…the study of how humans and
machines control and communicate information.
Walter moved to Boston after working
on the Manhattan Project during the
war years to work for Wiener, whom
he regarded as a father figure.
During their initial meeting, Wiener didn’t
say hello but instead, walked Walter over
to a blackboard where he was working out a
complex mathematical problem. Walter chimed
in with questions and suggestions, and
Wiener was impressed by the young man.
He later exclaimed that Walter was: “...without
question the strongest young scientist whom I have
ever met … I should be extremely astonished if he
does not prove to be one of the two or three most
important scientists of his generation, not
merely in America but in the world at large.”
He had profound confidence in Walter’s abilities
and believed his neural networks could
be implemented into man-made machines.
Although Walter’s work with McCulloch
was revolutionary, it was an overly
simplified representation of the brain; Wiener
wanted him to make his model more realistic.
He promised Walter a Ph.D. despite the fact
that he hadn’t even graduated high school.
Walter’s Ph.D. thesis focused on developing
an advanced version of his earlier brain
model using three-dimensional neural networks,
which was incredibly challenging and involved
some very complicated math, but those
who knew him were sure he’d succeed.
But instead of Walter’s career taking off,
it came crashing down when Wiener
suddenly cut ties with him.
Because Walter was close to
McCulloch, whom Wiener hated.
The rift began when the Director
of MIT’s Research Laboratory of
Electronics invited McCulloch to lead
a new brain research project at MIT.
Walter, along with his friend Jerry Lettvin,
and a young neuroscientist named Patrick Wall,
were part of the team exploring
how the nervous system processes
information and how machines
might mimic these functions.
Just as they were delving deeper into
the brain's workings, Wiener withdrew
his support from the group, reportedly
because his wife disapproved of McCulloch,
who had a penchant for alcohol and wild parties.
Margaret Wiener is said to have invented
a story and told her husband that when
their daughter Barbara stayed at McCulloch’s
house, several of “his boys” had seduced her.
It’s been suggested Margaret thought McCulloch’s
rise would threaten Wiener’s prominence at MIT.
Wiener immediately sent an angry
telegram to the MIT director:
Wiener abandoned Walter, the young
man whom he had taken under his wing.
The final nail in the coffin for Walter Pitts came
during a heartbreaking experiment involving frogs.
While it was believed that the eye took in
information and sent it to the brain for analysis,
Walter’s experiment found that
the frog’s eye itself processed
visual information like movement
before passing it on to the brain.
This contradicted Walter’s simpler, logical
model of the brain, in which he theorized
that the brain was the primary center
for processing all sensory information.
Turns out, reality was much more complex.
Lettvin recalled that the results
“...disappointed (Walter). He would
never admit it, but it seemed to add to his
despair at the loss of Wiener’s friendship.”
Walter destroyed his thesis, all of
his research, all of his life’s work.
With the exception of writing one more paper, he
did little else but drink for the next ten years.
Gone was his interest in science.
Gone were his interests in
anything he had been curious about,
from poetry to geology to
the birds of New England.
In the 1950s, he moved out of
Jerry Lettvin’s home because
his heavy drinking scared his friend’s children.
He spent the sixties in Boston’s bars,
changing his venue frequently so
that his friends couldn’t find him.
He was in such a bad state that he couldn’t
take care of his only companion, his dog.
On May 14, 1969, Walter Pitts died
alone of alcohol-related causes in
a boarding house in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
He was just 46 years old.
Pitts unknowingly set the stage for
modern computing and machine learning,
shaping a future that is
still evolving rapidly today.
Sadly, we’ll never know how much
further progress might have been
achieved had his journey not
been prematurely cut short.
Walter Pitts's innovations had
the power to change the world.
If you’re inspired to make a significant impact in
our digital era, or want to brush up on your math,
computer science, and data science
skills, I highly recommend Brilliant.
Brilliant is the best way to learn STEM
interactively, and it’s FREE for you to try out.
Unlike spending years in a traditional classroom,
Brilliant offers a hands-on approach to learning.
Their new Thinking in Code course gets
you designing simple programs to solve
real-world problems — like writing a program
that reminds you to exercise throughout the day.
As we live in a data-driven world, data
skills are only getting more in demand.
Brilliant’s Data Analysis Fundamentals
course will help you build your skillset
by focusing on the best ways to
visualize and interpret datasets.
link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
If you’re one of the first 200 people to sign up
for Brilliant’s Premium subscription, which gives
you access to their thousands of offerings,
you’ll get 20% off your Annual subscription.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.